my favorite genre of video today it's
videos of mothers going to school boards
and then my favorite sub-genre of this
genre is when mothers read materials
from the School classrooms and from the
school libraries and then the school
boards shut them down and tell them to
stop talking because that material is
inappropriate for the children in the
room the material from the classrooms
and the libraries that's inappropriate
for the children who might be in the
room at the school board meeting and a
prime example of this just took place in
Frisco Texas this would be Shannon Ayers
whose mother of two married for 30 years
was a small business owner in Frisco for
20 years now works with a national
organization called County Citizens
defending freedom in their Collin County
chapter Shannon thank you so much for
coming on the show
thank you Michael for having me so I
became aware of you
because you show up to the school board
and you're not flamboyant you're not
yelling you're not emotional you're not
wearing some silly costume you show up
like a normal person and you say here is
the material being read in the schools
this is obviously inappropriate and you
get out I don't know a few minutes of
this pornography before the school board
says hey you got to cut that out there
are children in the room
exactly yeah so um it's my site this was
my second time to actually go in front
of this school board I went last month
as well and they did let that one go but
this one um I think went viral because
the school board president her name is
Renee archambal I think so she says it
um stopped me even though I was actually
stopped my my mic had already been cut
and and I had already started to walk
away when she said I need you to stop
reading that because there's a child in
the room and I don't know I was just I'm
sure you heard the audience
um reaction to that which was the same
as mine like wow are you kidding me I
mean that's like my whole point that's
why I'm asking you to take this out of
the school library so
it kind of made a big splash do you
think that the the chairman of the
school board was she aware of how absurd
what she said sounded was she aware that
she had just made your point for you or
no she was actually just reacting in the
moment to the obvious obscenity that you
were reading
I don't think she was aware I don't
think she was aware I still don't know
that she's aware I I've heard Rumblings
that you know she was people are very
excited you know that people on the
other side of the of the issue were
thought it was great that she did that
I'm like okay but if you look at the
comments underneath the video
um that was posted online
99.9 of them are with me so of course I
can't believe that there is an other
side to the issue because the issue here
that we're talking about is should 14
year olds read porn in schools and it's
not just it's not even just normal porn
I mean they're they're obviously what
you were reading in that viral video was
gross but it was pretty uh
run-of-the-mill pornography but then in
your other appearance before the school
board you're reading a book that was in
the school library of a father
graphically and violently raping his
little daughter
yeah and I don't know if it's obvious in
what I read but um it was actually the
rape was being watched by her twin
sister and the twin sister was actually
longing for that type of affection from
the father
so it is a it was a pretty sick that in
my opinion that book was even worse than
what I read this last week
um of course and so I I just I mean that
man I can't believe that that scene
which was already so creepy somehow got
even creepier with that context I can't
can't say I'm familiar with that
author's work you know but right how is
there another side of this issue I just
don't get what kind of sicko could even
concoct an argument as to why 14 year
olds need to be exposed to pornography
of little girls longing for their father
to rape them the way they raped the way
the father raped the girl's twin sister
what's the argument
um the only argument that I'm hearing is
you know that it there might be a young
teen a young girl who's experiencing
that and needs to be able to see in
literature that she's not the only one
that things like this happen that she's
not alone something that she can
identify with
I mean that that's all I've heard that
that they've tried to use as an excuse
but but even let's say that there's some
poor girl who's being raped by her
father and she and this is why these
liberals who are running the school
libraries they say we need to have this
rape fantasy incest porn uh for the the
girl is being raped by her father
they're saying that the best way to
reach out to this girl is to present a
rape of a father to a daughter as
something to be longed for and
fantasized about right it makes no sense
I mean the child needs to be in therapy
obviously doesn't need to be reading a
book that it basically makes it seem
normal you know like it's you're not the
only one it's okay it happens no that's
not what we want to yeah well that's
amazing and you've you've just put that
into words what what they are doing
their actual argument is we need to
normalize this we need to normalize a
father raping his daughter that's the
best argument they've got for it that's
that's the best argument that I've heard
that is really good that is true truly
chilling so I I obviously the public is
with you I don't I don't need to take a
public opinion poll to note the public
is with you on this no one I mean this
has been a major political force now you
saw at McLean youngin election you saw
it in Ron desantis's elections in
Florida are you seeing it around the
country so how is the movement going I
mean obviously there are still these
crazy school board members there's still
this porn in schools where does the
whole thing stand
well unfortunately
um you know the only way you can remove
a school board member is with an
election and there's no no mechanism in
Texas to be able to recall or remove a
school board member so we have to wait
for elections and every election cycle
there's only you know a couple of seats
available to run for so last may we did
have an election three seats were up for
re-election we won two of those so we do
have two amazing
um
school board
members who are on our side who are
helping but they're of course not the
majority yet so they can only really get
the message out they can ask questions
during school board meetings they can
put things on the agenda for parents to
be aware but they can't you know they
lose most votes so um we're looking
forward to next may we have two more
seats up for uh re-election and we are
hoping to run two you know very
conservative board members who will
hopefully take those seats and then we
will have the majority but right now
um they this the district will tell you
that they are doing something about it
um they have you know updated their
Library review resources review process
we have a formal reconsideration process
then we have appeals processes that you
can go through the problem with that is
the book stays you know the book remains
on the shelves even during that process
the process is very lengthy
um the first book that that I read
um about the father and his daughter
that had been submitted back in August
um for reconsideration it passed the
first round of reconsideration so it was
appealed and it um I think it was in the
middle of appeal when I read the book
out loud and two days later is when it
was taken off the shelves so it was
eventually taken off the shelf
um Shannon do you think that had to do
with the precise timing of the appeals
process or do you think maybe you
shining a little bit of light on this
might have sped that process up a little
it might have I don't know know how long
that process generally takes or where it
was in that process but it might have it
might have interesting though that book
was written by an author who has many
books in our school libraries all across
the country she's a very popular author
um with teens and 15 books were removed
at that appeal during that appeal
process and 12 of them were this same
author the author who's the author if
you don't mind her name is Ellen Hopkins
Ellen Hopkins I gotta write your name
down the name of that book was
um identical it was about identical
twins
12 girls and and the incest Michael is
just one of many very disturbing topics
that that that book uh talks about it
talks about sadomasochism it talks about
cutting it talks about
um drugs there's a lot there's uh
prostitution I I mean there's everything
you can think of in that book so hard to
believe there's any redeeming value to
it at all you know sometimes when people
make perfectly Common Sense observations
like we don't need hardcore incest porn
in schools uh the rejoinder will be well
you're censoring art you don't you
Philistines are trying to get rid of
culture and and sometimes even people
will say you know there's a lot of bad
stuff in the Bible you know there's
incest in the Bible there's rape in the
but do you are you now advocating that
we ban the Bible and it brings me back
to really the center of the American
debate over obscenity which which
completely spun out of control in the
middle of the 20th century it comes back
to a Supreme Court Justice named Potter
Stewart who was asked how to define
pornography and obscenity and he said
you know I can't quite Define it but I
know it when I see it and and this line
is made fun of I mean it's it's a term
of of derision that is thrown at
conservatives but I don't really see why
it is made fun of when as far as I can
tell
you actually do know it when you see it
is that such a crazy observation you do
I mean there's this legal definition you
know of what obscenity is I don't know
why we need a legal definition because
you do know it when you see it
um but that's what they're you know
unfortunately in Texas there is a um
obscenity exemption clause in the law
and so if it's used in an educational
for an educational purpose then it's
allowed and that's what they're hiding
behind and and um you know the the
school that in the first amendment
they're saying it violates the child's
first amendment rights to pull these
books off of the Shelf which I mean I
spoke to that in my first video it's
like really I mean are we violating
their second amendment rights when we
tell them they can't carry a gun to
school no because they're children we're
talking about children they don't have
the same rights that we do as adults for
good reason so are we violating their
third amendment rights when we quarter
British soldiers in there well done
never mind but there are plenty of other
examples no of course we I mean first of
all since when does the the First
Amendment protect your right to be act
able to access any book you want at a
specific Library period even if you're
an adult but but then second of all to
suggest that children have this right do
children have the right to say whatever
they want in schools I don't think so I
think if I said naughty things in
schools the teacher would yell at me and
probably give me a bad grade
right and and you know I we get called
book burners a lot and ban you know
we're trying to ban books and my
argument for that is look
are we Banning cigarettes and alcohol
because we don't allow children to buy
cigarettes and alcohol are we Banning
movies because we don't allow them to
watch rated R rated X NC-17 movies or
re-banning all movies because of that
are rebanding guns because we don't let
them you know carry a gun or buy a gun
no we're just limiting their access
children's access to these things
because they're not mentally emotionally
ready for this kind of either physical
or mental harm I mean you don't you they
have their brains have to are so
right for I mean they're just so
impressionable is the word I'm looking
for at that age and so we have to
protect them where that's what we're
supposed to do as adults when did that
when did that stop we've always we've
always protected our kids and now all of
a sudden it's like oh no they're they're
they can handle it they need to see it
they need to know that they're not alone
um you know people they throw out the
whole
Bible thing and I actually saw somebody
online arguing that point and I'm like
okay name a Sunday school class where
the parts in the Bible about incest and
all of that are you know a Sunday school
class where they teach those passages
those passages you are hard even for an
adult sometimes to process and
understand so of course we're not going
to teach that to children in the
introduction to the Book of Genesis say
maybe wait a year or two before maybe
yeah yeah you know you stick with the
Noah's Ark you know and Adam and Eve you
know in the garden with the apple and
all of that you know you don't hit those
those topics that are really very
difficult even sometimes for adults to
understand so gotta protect the kids and
wait until their development they're
they're developmentally ready for that
type of
material I love it when people call me a
book burner and a book banner I always
say oh you're accusing me of banning and
burning books like um Plato or like um
the apostles in the book of Acts well or
like I don't know most Great Men
throughout history who have who have you
know beyond this kind of provocative
image of of burning books who have had
standards every society has standards
and we usually apply those standards in
a in a much stricter way when we're
talking about children and they they
pretend that we're sort of somehow
monsters or like we're fascists or
something because we want to have what
every society forever has always had
which is some kind of standard you know
I mean the the real irony of this of
course is that you know up until the
middle of the 20th century every school
just about taught the Bible and banned
pornography and now now so many schools
teach pornography and the one book you
are not allowed to teach in school it's
the only one you can teach mind conf you
can teach hardcore porn the one book you
can't teach is the Bible so who's really
doing the Banning here and what sort of
banning are they doing right it's a very
good point and the whole you know
standards thing yeah they're they're
definitely trying to it feels like
they're trying to lower the standards
every day lower and lower the bar gets
lower and lower and you can't I mean the
only thing I can I can assume is that
they're they're just wanting to
normalize this stuff so that kids their
their inhibitions are honestly I I
personally feel like they're trying to
lower the inhibitions of of children so
that when they are approached you know
by I
traffickers any any kind of
um
attempt to uh I don't know I mean the
pedophilia seems to be there's they seem
to be going towards even normalizing
that there's there are books in our
libraries that or have been I don't know
if they still are I don't quote me on
that but there have been that that
depict pedophilia you know lgbtq get gay
sex and and I don't I don't care no sex
sorry no sex neither book that I read
from had anything to do with the lgbtq
community and that's another
um that's another criticism that we get
is that we're just after you know this
certain uh segment of the population and
it's just not true then you say we don't
uh we don't want books about pederasty
in our schools they say how dare you
that's homophobic
no no you're the one who are a lot in
these two things but but of course uh
you know Shannon I can I can see you you
almost don't even want to say it you
don't even want to suggest that maybe
these guys are trying to normalize
pedophilia but of course we know that
that they are doing that I mean there
was a professor who was caught in a big
Scandal because she was caught on camera
trying to normalize pedophilia to change
even the word pedophile to map a minor
attracted person to take away the stigma
of the this orientation with which
people are born and you you see this
going on throughout the culture you're
seeing the normalization of drag queen
Story Hour what's that about it's about
bringing little kids into sexual
situations you're seeing on that same
line of thought uh drag kids these poor
little kids who are being sexually
abused and who put on little skimpy
dances and in in multiple cases have had
grown men put dollar bills in their
clothing I mean so this is not something
that you're imagining in some crazy
fever dream this is happening it's being
broadcast on the mainstream media and
and they tell us on the one hand
this is not happening it's a delusion of
the far right and on the other hand
they're saying this is happening it's so
wonderful and you better celebrate it
yeah the celebration part is where I
have an issue you know a lot of people
tell us especially as if you're a
Christian if you're a Believer we're to
love everybody and we are called to love
everybody
um but my definition of love is not
encouraging and celebrating something
that I think is destructive and and evil
so um you know I think we need to think
think twice about what our definition of
Love really is of course and you know
the way you can really prove the
absolute uh unprincipled character of
the the arguments that these people are
making is try to put a book in into the
school library that says that LGBT ism
is intrinsically disordered and it's a
grave mortal sin and people should not
do it and actually marriage is a union
between a man and a woman uh for life
for the good of the spouses and the sake
of the generation and education of
Children You Not only would they toss
the book out they probably would set it
on fire and they'd probably come to your
house with a pitchfork if you did that
absolutely absolutely it's very
hypocritical what which you know we saw
in the in the video when the hypocrisy
is I don't know how they don't see that
I really don't know how they don't see
that
I don't even know if they see it now of
course no of course and and to them you
know there's a good line from the
Harvard law professor Adrian vermeul he
says it's not hypocrisy it's hierarchy
they just think that there's one set of
rules for you and there's one set of
rules for us and that's the way that it
goes boy haven't we seen that in the
last several years of course and so in
many ways I mean I'm just so pleased to
hear that uh that you know this is
working and that you you know you're
getting a couple school board members
out there and you're actually doing what
the libs are very very good at and
conservatives usually are not that good
at conservatives are very good at
complaining and conservatives are very
good at sort of winding into a
microphone I've you know I I don't mean
to diminish my own profession here but
you know I think it's important to shed
light on these things but what the libs
are very good at is going out and
running for office and filling the
appointed positions and turning the
wheels of government not just at the
federal level but even all the way down
at the local level which is where a lot
of these really important rules are are
put into effect and you're actually
doing that and you're you're clearly
having results
well I hope so it seems slow going like
I said we've been we've been struggling
with this in Frisco for about a year
um and they say they're doing things and
they're really not they're really not
things that are working at least not
very quickly we even appropriated an
additional 450 000 Last Summer the the
board did of our taxpayer dollars
um to get this you know get the mess
cleaned up the mess that they originally
said we didn't really have right we
didn't really have the bugs in the
library at first and then we only had a
couple and then when it became clear
that it was you know a problem
um then they appropriated all this extra
money to get rid of all the books and
and they're still there that's why in my
first video I was like you know we're
still still after all of this we're
still plugged with these books in our
libraries and there's just no excuse for
it you don't have to read at first you
had to read the entire book before they
would let before they would they would
have a committee read the entire book
before they could decide whether or not
to remove it they couldn't just look at
that little excerpt and say okay that
that's not good they had to read the
book so the timing I mean it was up like
30 days they had to get the book uh
reviewed and in the meantime it's still
on the shelves for the kids to check out
so I do think it's you know maybe I'm
hoping that the the spotlight that you
and others are are putting on the
district will you know the public
pressure will will hopefully
um cause even more change quick more
quicker I certainly hope so and then
there's clicker there's of course a
Tipping Point which is right now you
know the the good guys are in the
minority on the school board but they've
got a representation and may become may
you tip that to the point that the
conservatives control the school board
and that's when we really see things
happen there was a report I read
recently I I it was a campaign that was
being run by moms for Liberty but it was
I forget the school district that it was
in uh but in any case the conservatives
took over the school board within two
hours they fired the superintendent they
fired the district lawyer they banned
critical race Theory they banned the
crazy gender curricula this was within
two hours what are they going to do in
two weeks what are they going to do in
two months I know I'm so excited to see
I think that was was that South Carolina
I think that was yes it was Berkeley
South Carolina I think yeah I was very
excited to see that and it you know it
gives you hope it gives you hope and
when you're in a district that's not
quite there yet going oh gosh when we
get there look at what we can do look at
the changes that we can make so I mean I
will say they have they have pulled you
know some of these books it's just like
pulling teeth and it shouldn't be so
hard it shouldn't be so hard to pull
complete depravity and you know
porn sexually explicit Material off our
school shelves it just it shouldn't be
it shouldn't shouldn't be hard I mean
forget the Liberals you know I mean
they've got their View and we're just
going to have to beat them at The Ballot
Box and beat them with the wielding of
political power but even some of these
squish quote-unquote conservatives and
Republicans who who just don't don't
have any sense of why this is a problem
and they don't want to deal with the
issue and they want to look away and
they say oh that's a culture War
distraction please let's just all I want
to do is talk about cutting taxes I love
tax cuts but come on there's more to
life than that and it seems that the
higher up you get in politics the the
more disconnected these people be common
so I really do hope that you stick
around the school district for a little
while you know keep this thing going get
the job done but then I really hope
Shannon people like you people like you
know a couple of conservative members of
that school school board people like
these moms Across America who who are
doing this
just let me know when you run for
Congress let me know where to send the
check because I would be more than happy
to do it ah thank you thank you I don't
know that running is in my future I feel
like I have a lot more um I could I can
have a lot more impact
um doing what I'm doing now so I haven't
been I've been asked before if I want to
run for school board I just think you
know you put a budget in front of me and
I'm just my eyes glaze over I don't want
to deal with that
yeah I I don't think I don't think I'd
be very I'd serve the public very well
in that capacity but
um you know right now I'm just working
with the county citizens defending
Freedom it's called ccdf go to the
website ccdfusa.com and they definitely
are all about taking action at the local
level because that's where it's at your
local level is where the the real impact
that's going to make a difference in
your life every day is in your local
school board city council mayor those
kinds of elections are the most
important so absolutely right Shannon
keep up the good work thank you for
coming on the Michael olds show thank
you I look forward to seeing more thanks
for having me
[Music]